It's important to consider these
values you set these parameters to,
as they can have a huge
impact on battery life.
As we saw with the priorities and
coarseness, battery usage is impacted
by which sensors you activate.
However and maybe with a bigger
impact is the interval that you use,
consider how often you really
want to read the sensors.
In this case, you can see we ping them
once a second, which isn't too bad.
But do you really need
that level of accuracy?
What would happen if you
were more accurate and
pinged them a hundred times a second?
What would your app experience
be like if you ping them
once every ten minutes instead?
These are the type of questions
that you need to consider for
your users, when designing an app
that uses location services.
So for example, an app for
a hockey coach might want very frequent
updates of players' locations
on the ice during a game.
So the coach can plot
that data after the game,
to see the players' effectiveness.
Conversely, an app that tells
you if your kids are home yet
might only need to check your location
details a few times per hour.